[Music]
here's a look at kensington palace in
london where there is exciting news this
morning from the royal family welcome
back to cbs this morning prince
william's wife kate is expecting baby
number three the overnight announcement
revealed that she faces a familiar
health problem with her newest pregnancy
charlie dagda is outside kensington
palace charlie good morning
good morning the news broke in a
surprise announcement from kensington
palace here where kate is currently
being treated these are people marking
the memorial of the death of princess
diana 20 years ago
the announcement came the timing
announcement probably has to do with the
fact that kate had to cancel a scheduled
appointment at a children's hospital
today because according to the
announcement she's suffering from
hyperemesis gravidarum severe morning
sickness
kate who is now 35 suffered from acute
morning sickness when she was carrying
prince george who's now four and
princess charlotte who's now two as a
matter of fact she was hospitalized
while carrying prince george the palace
says for now she's going to be treated
here at kensington palace by medical
staff the queen and both families are
said to be delighted with the news
bookies were always banking on at least
three children from william and kate who
are now looking at a royal flush if not
a full house jeff nice charlie daggett
thank you very much outside kensington
palace